[Musique]
oui
re bonjour à toutes et à tous et
bienvenue pour cette seconde table ronde
dont nous allons parler de la
conciliation de deux sujets majeurs à la
fois de notre époque mais aussi de nos
préoccupations de responsables
politiques
concilier croissance et écologie et je
suis très heureux d'accueillir
l'ensemble de ces deux des participants
pour pour cette table ronde de la qui
sera sur le même format que celle que
vous avez vécu à l'instant on vous donne
la parole pour vous puissiez participer
je suis très heureux d'accueillir damien
abad président du groupe l'est
républicain à l'assemblée nationale que
je vous demande d'applaudir et très
engagée sur sur ces questions et qui je
le sais a beaucoup de conviction à nous
faire partager
je suis très heureux d'accueillir
florian delmas directeur général du
groupe andros gens diraient quelques
mots tout à l'heure on se tutoie rats
tous parce qu'on se tutoie dans la vraie
vie donc je pense qu'on continuera sans
hypocrisie à le faire et vous pouvez
l'applaudir parce que sa présence et est
tout à fait importante
je salue geoffroy et et sophie qui sont
avec nous je froid responsable
départemental jeunes des yvelines qui va
nous parler de ce qui s'est dit lors des
ateliers de la journée d'hier et et
sophie qui en dira quelques mots y
compris pour vous inviter à participer
durant ces débats avant que nous
commencions je voudrais juste vous
rappeler qu' il ya quelques décennies un
président de la république qui
s'appelait georges pompidou a été le
premier à placer la question de
l'environnement au coeur du débat public
il ya quelques décennies c'est georges
pompidou qui le premier créé le premier
ministère de l'environnement
sipa la gauche qui le fait c'est la
droite républicaine qui le fait il y a
quelques années de cela c'est le
président jacques chirac qui prononce à
johannesbourg un discours historique
c'est eux le président jacques chirac
qui prononce ces mots
attention à ce que l'humanité ne
provoque pas un crime contre la vie
c'est notre famille politique qui tire
cette semaine d alarme c'est jacques
chirac le même qui fondent dans la
constitution la charte de
l'environnement
nous n'avons pas attendu les débats
d'aujourd'hui pour le faire il ya
quelques décennies de cela et c'est
enfin nicolas sarkozy qui lance le
grenelle de l'environnement
dès son élection dès son arrivée
à la présidence de la république bref
l'histoire de la droite est intimement
liée à l'histoire de la préservation de
l'environnement en 70 georges pompidou à
chicago dans le temple de ceux qui
commencent à être la mondialisation
prononcer un discours majeur dans ce
discours là il dit que nous avons
collectivement une responsabilité place
et la morale de l'environnement au coeur
des décisions publiques et des actes de
chacun
c'est pas un affreux gauchiste qui le
dit c'est georges pompidou en 70 à
l'époque où personne ne questionne le
mode de développement qui est
aujourd'hui le nôtre
bref les celles et ceux qui ont été les
plus capables de poser les bonnes
questions sur l'écologie sur
l'environnement c'est notre famille
politique
ne l'oublions pas et soyons en fiers
derrière ce sujet là nous allons ouvrir
beaucoup de débats vers la question
d'écologie de la croissance nous allons
interroger l'environnement sa
préservation
interrogé nos modes de consommation
interrogé notre économie interrogé
l'ensemble des sujets qui font
qu'aujourd'hui notre société se
questionne et souhaite trouver sa place
au sein d'un développement durable pour
parler de tout cela
nos intervenants auront la parole chacun
va prendre la s'exprimer pour planter le
décor dire ses convictions et sa vision
des choses
vous aurez ensuite la parole dans le
même format que ce que vous avez pu
connaître tout à l'heure et je vous
invite véritablement à intervenir les
uns et des autres je passe immédiatement
la parole à sophie qui va nous dire
quelques mots
ensuite geoffroy qui nous fera le bilan
de la journée d'hier
et puis nos intervenants qui
poursuivront les échanges merci aurélien
et aux participants de cette table ronde
alors effectivement hier on a commencé à
m avec mes collègues raphaël chanal
berger julien dive alexandre vincent deh
et tous les jeunes qui ont participé
assidûment à cette table ronde des
débats sur la table tout de suite des
lignes de conduite nous on a considéré
directement qu'on était dans la
conciliation aujourd'hui de la
croissance et de l'écologie parce que
des investissements et les chefs
d'entreprise prennent souvent le lead
sur ces questions là peut-être même
parfois avant l'action publique c'était
un
une des thématiques qu'on souhaitait
aborder elle fait débat
on est là pour pour en parler et en tout
cas dans les fonctions qui sont les
miennes sur le développement économique
en région normandie et bien on constate
un effort d'investissement qui
mériterait certainement d'être portée au
meilleur niveau qui soit c'est les
propos de françois xavier tout à l'heure
et d'agnès au niveau européen nous avons
aussi et nous souhaiterions pouvoir vous
entendre en tant que dirigeant
d'entreprise abordé le sujet de la
décroissance qui n'est pas dans la nôtre
adn économique mais qui fait débat au
sein de vos échanges entre jeunes on
vous entendra peut-être tout à l'heure
nous on a une vision de défi positif
chez les républicains nous défendons
dans l'action dans l'action publique est
évidemment le fait de se dire pour vous
les jeunes vous avez osé mettre dans nos
débats
le fait que pour vous une politique de
développement durable au sein d'une
entreprise pouvait être un élément
d'attractivité dans vos choix non
seulement dans vos choix professionnel
mais dans l'emploi on est aussi là pour
débattre de ces questions
voilà merci d'avoir élargi au maximum
avec une grande liberté de ton
le la possibilité d échange de ce matin
deux minutes j'ai tenu
bon j'ai deux minutes également plus
cette seconde qui ont pas été prises
donc c'est bon bon déjà je suis content
de voir encore autant de jeunes parce
que je sais que beaucoup sont sortis
hier donc bravo à tous d'être encore là
et aujourd'hui ça va être l'occasion
d'approfondir justement ce que ce que
l'on s'est dit hier on a beaucoup
discuté donc d'écologie réinterroger la
croissance déjà vous étiez nombreux à
vouloir intervenir sur sur ces
thématiques puisque enfin on vous
donnait la parole
enfin on donnait la parole à la jeunesse
et enfin ont donné la parole aux bons
jeunes
parce que généralement quand donne la
parole à des jeunes sur l'écologie s'est
jamais des jeunes de droite donc ces
caisses qui faisait en fait on s'est
interrogé qu'est ce qui fait que vous
vous êtes sensibilisé à la cause
environnementale mais en même temps vous
êtes de droite c'est que vous avez au
fond de vous ce pragmatisme qui vous dit
que vous devez concilier quand même
cette urgence économique à cette urgence
climatique
on a parlé donc iyh aires d'alimentation
beaucoup d'alimentation de ruralité de
produits importés qui ne respectaient
pas les normes donc ça sera peut-être
l'occasion d'en discuter mais je pense
que ça a été abordé un peu plus tôt ce
matin avec l'europe
on a également parlé d'aménagement du
territoire
voilà on a beaucoup pente assez les
personnes dans les villes pendant des
années et aujourd'hui toutes ces
personnes sont en quête de nature en
quête d' espaces de respiration et donc
c'est un sujet qui a à prendre dès
maintenant et à étudier pour
mieux vaut mieux mettre en place cet
aménagement du territoire
on a parlé également d'accords de
libre-échange toujours sur ses produits
de compétitivité
de compétitivité par rapport aux
produits étrangers
et puis on a parlé également with de
cette croissance
on a réinterrogé cette croissance il y
en a qui ont même parlé de décroissance
de se dire à quoi sert cette croissance
alors les pistes qui étaient apportées
c'était évidemment balle à la croissance
et à créer de la richesse à créer de la
valeur ajoutée et on se demandait aux
maîtres cette valeur ajoutée je crois
que l'essentiel en fait c'était cette
quête de sens dont nous ont fait part
les jeunes ou est ce qu'on met nos
investissements dans os que l'on mène
aux investissements et où est ce que
l'on met cette valeur ajoutée et puis
enfin on a un dernier sujet qui
peut-être mériterait d'être approfondie
aujourd'hui c'est la question du mix
énergétique sur les énergies
renouvelables qu'on a moins eu le temps
de développer donc potentiellement qui
peuvent être développées développer ce
matin donc c'est l'essentiel de ce qui
s'est dit
je voulais juste passer un message à
tous les jeunes ce matin je sais que le
format est beaucoup plus intimidant qui
hier en atelier où nous étions en format
plus
resserrée donc n'hésitez surtout pas à
prendre la parole
vous êtes là pour ça ce matin et nos
intervenants sont là évidemment pour
vous répondre merci à tous merci
beaucoup geoffroy avant de laisser la
parole à un florian delmas je voudrais
vous dire deux trois mots de
présentation et puis le remercier
florian delmas et donc le directeur
général de l'entreprise du groupe andros
entreprises qui a beaucoup de qualités
notamment une parce que ces entreprises
lotoises dont naturellement tout ce qui
vient du lot par définition porto semble
de qualité
personne ne le contestera et notamment
pas aujourd'hui mais je voudrais le
remercier d'abord on a passé un peu de
temps ensemble je connais ses valeurs
humaines je le dis pas pour lui faire
plaisir mais parce que l son véritable
il est fils d'un éleveur de lozère il a
un parcours dont il vous parlera
sûrement qu'il ne le prédestinait pas à
véritablement à devenir directeur
général d'un groupe comme comme endroit
aussi la 35 ans andros c'est aujourd'hui
22 pays
plus de 48 zine si je dis pas de bêtises
et 10000 collaborateurs dans le monde
c'est un des plus beaux groupes
industriels agroalimentaires que nous
ayons dans notre pays et florian va
sortir le 15 octobre un livre il n'ya
pas que les politiques qui font des
livres quelqu'un florian suicide il l'a
véritablement écrit lui-même
il s'appelle planète à plan b il nous en
parlera et je veux le remercier parce
que c'est une des premières fois je
crois qu'il participe un rendez vous
politique ce n'est pas un militant c'est
quelqu'un qui tiendra des propos de
chefs d'entreprises de responsables
d'entreprises et sa présence est un
véritable signe et je veux que vous
l'applaudissent y est que vous le
remercier parce que c'est pas une
évidence et sa présence est pour nous
capitale florian tu as la parole
merci merci aurélien merci à toutes et
tous t'ont vous assurez vous je vais pas
faire la publicité de mon livre et
j'ai un avantage c'est que j'ai une
neutralité en tant que dirigeant j'ai
bien dis en tant que dirigeants et donc
que je vais pouvoir me permettre au delà
de la flatterie quelques commentaires le
premier mon étonnement c'est que quand
le sujet de l'écologie est arrivé sur la
table j'ai vu une grande partie des gens
quitter la salle et ça m'étonne et ça
m'inquiète un petit peu par rapport aux
enjeux du 21e siècle mais je m'aperçois
qu'ils remontent donc c'était un besoin
vital aller uriner je les en remercie de
venir écouter le sujet ce thème et qui
m'est cher entre guillemets est
important parce qu'il permet de vous
réconcilier avec vous même réconcilier
la croissance donc l'économie avec
l'écologie ça n'a pas de sens et je vous
l'expliquais et je vais vous expliquer
mes convictions sur le sujet je suis là
pour vous perturber et venir percuter
des schémas de pensée aujourd'hui qu'ils
ont été construits qui ne sont plus les
bons sur la base de modèles qu'il faut
réinventer et je crois à l'entreprise et
aux politiques pour pouvoir les
réinventer et donc je vais aborder le
sujet en deux temps le premier c'est une
question fermée
peut-on réconcilier l'écologie et
l'économie la croissance et la deuxième
la question ouverte si nous pouvons
comment pouvons-nous faire
et donc pour répondre à la première
question il faut repartir du nom et ce
nom de deux mots l'écologie d'un côté et
la croissance de l'autre et aujourd'hui
vous parler de votre famille depuis hier
et moi je vais vous parler de votre
maison
donc on oublie votre famille on parle de
notre maison et c'est la maison à tous
quel que soit votre famille finalement
quand on reprend l'étymologie du mot
écologie il ya un hic hausse la maison
et logos la science de la maison il
s'agit entre autres de comprendre les
liens et les interactions entre les
êtres vivants d'un côté et leurs
environnements de l'autre et quand on
prend le deuxième mot la croissance ont
leurs attaches immédiatement au pib
cette invention de 1934 qui a été fait
par les américains dans le but
d'apporter un ordre comptable mondial et
qui a été reprise par la france en 1946
après
la guerre pour uniformiser cet ordre
mondial autour d'un indicateur que vous
mettez dans cette dans cette thématique
comme étant une fin en soi mais qui
n'est pas ni un objectif ni une fin en
soi c'est un indicateur le pib le revenu
généré dans un pays et qui étroitement
attachés au modèle économique qui a
voulu être construits économie on a une
chance écho aux 'echos' la maison nomos
l'administration de la maison
alors je sais pas si vous me suivez
mais en fait vous avez d'un côté la vie
de l'autre le pèze vous avez d'un côté
quelque chose de dynamique de systémique
l'écosystème de l'autre quelque chose de
rigide de fixer de normaliser de
standardiser et vous avez d'un côté
quelque chose l'écosystème qui est ce
qui a de plus globale et qui doit vous
traversez en tant qu'individu qui doit
vous traversez en tant que partisan
politique et de l'autre une petite
composantes à savoir le modèle
économique qui n'est qu'un petit bout de
notre grand écosystème dans lequel nous
vivons est donc dans l'entreprise en
tout cas c'est les valeurs que je porte
mais je pense que dans le monde
politique aussi l'écologie qui a été
dévoyé à travers son mot sa définition
et qui a pris un sens politique
aujourd'hui
et finalement ce qui doit traverser
chaque individu chaque citoyen chaque
éco citoyens à travers le monde
ce n'est pas un parti pris ce n'est pas
un parti politique c'est le fondement
même de nos sociétés
autrement dit pas de politique je
n'étais pas partisan mais l'écologie n'a
pas de raison d'être
elle doit être dans tous les partis
politiques et moins en tant que patron
d'entreprise quand je parle
développement durable je n'ai pas de
service développement durable
je n'ai pas de service rsa c'est moi qui
porte la rse parce que la rse c'est la
façon de faire nos affaires au sein de
notre entreprise en essayant de
concilier les enjeux sociaux les enjeux
environnementaux et les enjeux
économiques également et qu'à travers ce
raisonnement
premièrement il ya une première
conclusion c'est qu'on oppose des choses
qui ne peuvent pas se réconcilier
clairement et qui en a une qui est
dominante sur l'autre c'est l'écologie
donc l'éco système dans lequel nous
vivons
vertus ce un petit bout de ce système
qui est l'économie deuxièmement j'ai
fait un peu d'histoire en revenant en
l'économie elle se construit ou en tout
cas les indicateurs de pilotage d'une
activité d'une économie dans le monde
politique dans le monde économique y est
dans le monde de l'entreprise
elle se construit sur la base d'une
ambition sur la base d'un souhait sur la
base d'un but que l'on recherche
et plutôt que de définir la croissance
comme une fin en soi j'aimerais vous
faire réfléchir sur la notion de progrès
en tant que parti politique vous devez
définir finalement quel progrès vous
voulez donner en 2050 pour la france et
on a une chance extraordinaire c'est que
le progrès n'est pas quelque chose
d'absolu à l'instant t il n'y a pas de
progrès mais quelque chose de relatif
c'est à dire que c'est quelque chose que
vous pouvez construire et pour le
construire il faut des hommes courage
des hommes et des femmes courageux
pardon un homme avec un grand h des
hommes et des femmes courageux
ça fait partie de la modernité également
et ce courage vous devez le porter parce
que moi ce que je vous amène à réfléchir
c'est finalement de recomposer le modèle
économique tel qu'il a été construit
vous avez en charge l'administration de
la maison et moi je vis dans cette
maison et je suis en tant qu'entreprise
partie prenante de cet écosystème à côté
de vous ce modèle économique que vous
avez construit ce modèle social que vous
essayez de construire est donc
finalement plutôt que de définir la
croissance comme une fin en soi plutôt
de définir la croissance comme un
objectif raisonnée écosystèmes
premièrement et définissez le but
souhaité pour la société et je suis
désolé en 2020 les enjeux de notre
nation ne sont plus ceux de 1930 de 1932
à l'industrialisation galopante
récession hallucinante guerre 2020
récession extrêmement probable si
l'inflation il n'y a pas et
développement hallucinant du numérique
on est dans des contextes très opposés
et en même temps très proche
conclusion changer vite le modèle défini
c'est un nouveau but
définissez l'indicateur pilote de
pilotage de ce nouveau but
il ne peut plus être exclusivement le
pib asseyez vous sur le pib
asseyez vous sur la croissance dès lors
qu'on considère qu'elle apporte plus
d'événements négatifs que d'éléments de
progrès en redéfinissant votre but et en
redéfinissant en indicateurs et bien sûr
pas ces indicateurs que tous les experts
réfléchissent est à dire d scorecard
avec 25 30 40 critères qui permettront
de savoir si on veut bien si on fait
bien kaka si on dort bien si on se lève
le matin si on mange bien non il faut en
trouver un et je vais vous achèterez pas
le livre c'est pas grave je vais vous en
dévoiler un qui arrive en conclusion et
qui est finalement plus baser sur cette
logique de croissance qui est le modèle
capitalistique américain qui consiste à
dire que pour exister il faut être gros
et que pour être gros il faut manger les
petits et que pour être gros il faut
produire pas cher et donc il faut aller
exploiter des ressources avec les
meilleurs les moyens les plus évolués
possible en ne donnant une valeur à la
ressource qui la plus faible possible
pour en tirer une valeur ajoutée la plus
forte possible
c'est finalement comme dans le monde de
l'entreprise on n'analyse pas une
entreprise exclusivement je pense
beaucoup qui font des écoles de commerce
ici par son chiffre d'affaires
donc par son produit intérieur brut on
valorise une entreprise par son résultat
et donc le résultat c'est le produit
intérieur brut - des charges et si nous
considérons que le progrès social
aujourd'hui ne peut plus dépendre
exclusivement du progrès économique dont
de la croissance et que nous devons
intégrer une deuxième composante qui est
le progrès environnemental eh bien il
faut définir un nouvel indicateur qui
allie les deux est au 21ème siècle
progrès évident environnementale pardon
doit reposer sur un seul et unique
projet désolé pour les écologistes
radicaux c'est la régulation carbonée
celle qui nous permettra de continuer à
respirer ou non faire société pour
l'essentiel c'est le sous titre de mon
livre ramène trois éléments essentiels à
la vie quand je n'ai je respire j'ai
faim donc je mange et si je suis malade
je me soigne mais la santé elle vient en
troisième lieu je respire régulation
carbonée je mange donc alimentation
supply chain alimentaire
troisièmement pardon super alimentaire
et notion de biodiversité indispensable
et troisièmement je me
je me soigne et donc j'ai imaginé ce que
j'ai appelé lundi échos 'l'indice de la
maison finalement qui allie à la fois le
logos logique et le nomos
le modèle l'administration de cette
maison par l'indicé co que j'ai appelé
aussi le r&b le résultat intérieur brut
et le résultat intérieur brut c'est le
pib - le coût carbone intérieur brut
autrement dit le coût carbone de ce que
nous fabriquons le pardon est ce que
nous fabriquons en france de valeur
brute et auxquels je soustrais
finalement tous les mécanismes
compensations auxquelles nos entreprises
ne pourront souscrire aujourd'hui pour
pouvoir le libérer et j'arrive à un
résultat intérieur but est tout de suite
je construis de nouvelles perspectives
qui est la suivante c'est que si pour
évaluer le progrès de demain d'une
société qui est basée sur un enjeu
économique et sur un enjeu
environnemental
je m'appuie sur ce reboot sur cet indice
échos j'ajoute une dimension qualitative
à la dimension quantitative et je viens
tout de suite dire que si je continue à
faire de la croissance de chiffre
d'affaires et de pib et que je réduis
mon empreinte carbone je suis dans un
monde en croissance
et puisque vous êtes tous depuis 80 ans
au sens tant attachés à cette croissance
est bien continuons la croissance
puisque la croissance est belle et la
croissance et ses progrès merci merci
beaucoup
florian pour pour tes propos qui vont
nous permettre d'animer le débat je
passe la parole à notre président du
groupe est républicain damien abad pour
son propos introductif et ensuite on
vous laisse la parole pour les échanges
de deux minutes
merci beaucoup aurélien mercier merci à
toi et permettant de saluer toute
l'équipe ici présente bien sûr en
premier
christian notre président du parti tous
les parlementaires qui sont qui sont là
alors bien sûr une pensée particulière
pour nos députés pas parce que
simplement ils sont les plus nombreux en
nombre ce matin mais mais aussi parce
que il écoute les débats avec avec
attention et merci à vous d'être là tous
les députés également européens et tous
les élus et surtout tous ces jeunes qui
sont là et je voudrais juste avant
d'ouvrir le débat
cher aurélien de remercier toi pierre
henri christian parce que c'est un vrai
pari que d'amener et de faire en sorte
qu'on ait 48 heures comme ça de débat
avec tous ces jeunes qui sont venus
nombreux et pour avoir été
président des jeunes quand j'étais
vraiment jeune je peux je sais que
mobiliser tous ces jeunes à 9 heures du
matin à 10 heures du matin après une
longue soirée c'est jamais facile alors
un grand bravo et surtout le message
vous faire passer bravo à houilles
exactement surtout surtout soyez
optimiste je sais que la mode est au
climat à la morosité et d'être
finalement dépressif et de ne pas avoir
le moral d'être pessimiste d'abord le
premier message qu'on doit vous faire
passer ici c'est qu'il faut qu souffle à
nouveau à la fois pour la droite mais
aussi pour la france
un vent d'optimisme d'espérance et de
volonté et quand on est jeune et de
droite
on doit croire à l'espoir à l'audace et
on doit être également optimiste
personne n'a le monopole de l'optimisme
bien entendu et pour ouvrir cette table
ronde
d'abord vous dire qu'il y à une urgence
climatique et écologique et que cette
urgence
elle est centrale elle est au milieu de
notre nez regardons les choses en face
l'urgence climatique c'est ce
réchauffement climatique qui arrive bien
entendu vers nous qui fait que le
réchauffement de la planète si on ne
fait rien et si on laisse continuer et
poursuivre finalement la vie telle
qu'elle se passe aujourd'hui c'est 4
degrés supplémentaires dans 100 ans et
que ça c'est un impact direct le
réchauffement climatique ce n'est pas la
météo vous voyez tous les jours c'est
pas de savoir s'il ya des épisodes de
canicules ou des épisodes depuis non le
réchauffement climatique
c'est tout simplement regarder la fonte
des glaciers le fait que si nous ne
faisons rien et bien dans son temps il
n'y aura plus de glaciers dans le monde
et c'est ça la réalité la réalité de
l'urgence écologique c'est que toutes
les 20 minutes
il ya une espèce animale ou végétale qui
disparaît la réalité d'urgence
écologique c'est que si nous restons les
bras croisés et bien dans 50 ans nous
aurons 250 millions de réfugiés
climatiques
aujourd'hui on est en débat sur la
question de reconfirmer sanitaires je
voudrais pas que demain on ait des
débats sur les questions de coûts
finement climatique parce que nous
aurions pu en capacité de vivre dans
notre planète compte tenu de nos
comportements et des politiques qui sont
menées
il faut aussi savoir que l'urgence pour
nous écologique c'est aussi bien sûr
l'alimentation je pense que on en
parlera tout à l'heure mais je vous
donne juste se chiffre aujourd'hui il y
à un tiers un tiers des aliments que
nous consommons dans le monde qui sont
gaspillées un tiers ce qui est bien sûr
totalement considérable et ce qui nous
montre que quoi et bien que et vous
l'avez dit tout à l'heure
ce directeur général à juste titre c'est
que face à cette urgence écologique on
peut pas c'est un projet de société qui
nous concerne toutes et tous et ça peut
pas être le fait d'un seul parti
politique ça nous concerne tous bien sûr
nous les jeunes bien sûr nous les
militants de droite mais j'ai envie de
dire aussi l'ensemble des françaises et
les français est la première grande
erreur je pense que nous commettons
c'est quand nous pensons où nous voulons
nous nous laissons finalement parler
d'écologie uniquement celles et ceux qui
auraient le label sur un logo non c'est
pas avoir un logo pour parler d'écologie
c'est au contraire agir au concret et
prendre en compte cette urgence
écologique et climatique est essentielle
et centrale et en plus la droite et
aurélien l'a rappelé tout à l'heure à
juste titre non seulement n'a pas à
rougir de ce qu'elle a fait en matière
environnementale et écologique
mais c'est même elle qui a porté les
jalons de cette cause écologique tout au
long du xxème siècle et tu l'as dit et
soyons clairs les parcs naturels
régionaux
c'est le général de gaulle qui les a mis
en place par un décret le ministère de
l'environnement
c'est effectivement georges pompidou la
loi sur le convainc ses relations d
espace littoral c'est le président
giscard d'estaing qui l'a mise en oeuvre
la charte sur l'environnement
c'est le président jacques chirac il a
lancé et bien sûr le grenelle de
l'environnement c'est aussi le président
nicolas sarkozy qui je rappelle lors de
la présidence française de l'union
européenne avait fait du paquet énergie
climat
un élément central de la politique en
france mais aussi en europe
alors nous n'avons pas à rougir n'avons
pas à nous excuser et nous n'avons pas à
dire que parce qu'on est de droite
on n'aurait pas le droit et même le
devoir de parler d'écologie tous
ensemble et c'est ça un enjeu majeur
bien sûr pour
et puis il nous faut aussi comprendre
clairement comment on peut articuler
notre discours en face on a
effectivement un modèle d'une écologie
décroissante d'une écologie punitive de
la sanction et on le constate encore
aujourd'hui je suis député de l'ain je
les constate est à lyon dans la ville de
lyon où désormais avec l'arrivée
écologistes au pouvoir et bien c'est la
fin de l'aéroport de lyon-saint-exupéry
la fermeture de projets comme des
correspondances avec montréal par
exemple la fin du bouclage périphériques
et surtout l'interdiction des voitures
en ville ce n'est pas réduire la
pollution
c'est simplement la déplacer la déplacer
sur les territoires qui sont autour
et c'est encore davantage creuser la
fracture territoriale qu'il ya
aujourd'hui et je voudrais pas que
l'écologie soit un prétexte pour qu'on
creuse encore la fracture qu'il y a
entre nos territoires entre nos
métropoles nos territoires périurbains
et nos territoires ruraux et là je crois
que la droite elle a beaucoup de choses
également à dire là-dessus bien entendu
notre écologie elle doit être bien sûr
positive pragmatique efficace pas abordé
ici tous les sujets on aura l'occasion
lors des débats mais peut-être juste un
ou deux je crois que d'abord ce qui doit
faire notre différence c'est que la
manière dont nous envisageons l'écologie
n'est pas une opposition entre l'homme
et la nature
vous avez aussi aujourd'hui beaucoup de
mouvements qui prospère dans la société
française pensa l'antispécisme à tous
les mouvements qui se créent et qui
repose sur un présupposé qui est de dire
que finalement l'homme est par essence
mauvais pour la nature et que donc on
pourra aborder la cause écologique
uniquement en posant l'un à l'autre nous
croyons au contraire linverse nous
pensons que c'est par l'humain que c'est
par la responsabilité de chacun que
parce que l'écologie la sphère de tous
et pas simplement celle des autres pas
simplement celle des états et des
gouvernants mais la sphère de tout ce
que nous devons réconcilier
effectivement trouvé ces voies de cette
écologie humaine et c'est comme cela
qu'on arrivera à concilier écologie et
croissance j'ai bien entendu ce qui a
été dit je pense qu'il faut inventer de
nouvelles formes de croissance
alors bien sûr
ce qu'on appelle la croissance durable
on le sait on doit aujourd'hui moi je
considère je suis de ceux en tout cas
qui pensent que c'est pas parce que on
veut défendre un projet écologique qu'on
doit abandonner les grands projets
d'infrastructure au contraire quelle est
la cohérence entre l'abandon de la lgv
lyon turin et le fait de vouloir
développer d'un côté le fret pour
réduire justement les transports par
camion c'est là où il ya beaucoup
d'incohérences et de contradictions et
c'est à nous de créer ce projet là sur
des logements bien sûr avec de la
rénovation thermique sur bien sûr la
question alimentaire des circuits courts
des l'économie de proximité qui est
absolument essentiel et de la politique
agricole commune sur également bien
entendu les déplacements au quotidien
mais là aussi il ya ceux qui veulent
reconstruire le monde descend le monde
descend voiture le monde descend
infrastructures et ceux qui construisent
au contraire le monde avec et donc pour
conclure sur cette introduction de la
table ronde
je dirais que pour nous notre rôle notre
objectif aujourd'hui à droite il doit
être clair c'est que on doit proposer
aux françaises et aux français expliqué
qu'en fait il n'y a pas un choix
écologique il n'y a pas un choix
d'environnement mais il ya deux visions
de la société
deux visions du rapport entre l'écologie
et l'économie et que notre vision c'est
une vision pragmatique concrète d'une et
l'écologie du quotidien qui se vit tous
les jours par tout le monde et qui
surtout porte en soi ces éléments de
politiques publiques qui sont essentiels
et centre pour nous et surtout qui
permettent
eh bien je crois à chaque jeune est
notamment bien sûr aux jeunes qui sont
militants dans notre famille politique
est bien de porter cet étendard là et de
faire en sorte que sur cette écologie et
bien non seulement on ne s'excuse plus
non seulement on n'hésite plus que l'on
comprenne que c'est l'enjeu numéro un et
que parce que c'est l'enjeu numéro un
parce que c'est un enjeu prioritaire
parce que tout simplement c'est un enjeu
vital pour nous pour nos enfants et pour
nos petits enfants dans l'avenir qu'on
doit pas laisser les autres s'en occuper
à notre détriment alors c'est à nous de
se saisir de ce sujet et de se saisir
avec conviction avec envie et avec
détermination
merci beaucoup damien pour pour ces
propos qui nous permettent de lancer le
débat désormais vous avez la parole
et je vous invite donc à poser la
première question alors je me vois très
mal de loin donc il faut m'excuser mais
je vois une main ici vous a énormément
des perches qui vont être tendu voilà
alors non à les compteurs pour deux
minutes
donc on fait comme à l'assemblée
nationale de rugby était un spécialiste
de ça au bout de deux minutes on coupe
et deux minutes pour les réponses c'est
à toi bonjour bonjour je m'appelle
nicollin je viens de saint quentin dans
l'aisne je suis républicain et je
souhaitais savoir pourquoi actuellement
il ya certains produits chimiques qui
sont interdits dans les champs français
mais pourtant que l'autorisent exporter
de l'étranger
ecall héros mais dans nos magasins eco
décale le problème sont vraiment le
régler est à côté de st pour payer
autant de taxes que ça vient de loin que
directement à côté de chez nous
qu'est-ce que vous recommander à
rectifier ce tir à l'avenir merci
beaucoup on va prendre une seconde
question et qui ensuite je laisserais
nous intervenons y répondre alors pour
le perchiste aussi le plus simple je
vous laisse faire
bonjour augustin je suis responsable de
la formation dans le département du nord
et je suis élu à marcq en baroeul je
voudrais d'abord saluer raphaël scheelen
berger qui est secrétaire général à la
formation c'est bien c'est bien et est
avec l'écologie on a un vrai sujet de
formation parce que la formation c'est
quoi c'est de mettre des billes dans le
débat pour nous aider à faire valoir nos
idées et je voudrais juste posé trois
chiffres et poser de questions le
premier c'est que notre empreinte
carbone en france elle est de 11,2
tonnes d'émissions de co2 par habitant
et pour atteindre l'objectif à 2050 il
faudrait qu'on en consomme moins de 3
donc on est à quatre fois plus que ce
qu'on devrait consommer donc il faut pas
juste ajuster nos modes de consommation
faut vraiment disrupt et le le système
et je voudrais poser un deuxième
chiffres c'est que dans cette empreinte
carbone la part des importations a plus
que doublé depuis 1995 donc il faut
vraiment réfléchir à la place de la
france dans son dans cette économie
mondialisé et du coup ma question est
les doubles vous chefs d'entreprise
comment est ce que vous vivez par
rapport à ce constat là comment vous
changer les modes d'approvisionnement
les modes de distribution pour que le
circuit court cette fois pas juste un
phénomène de mode mais juste un enjeu
vital pour que la maison arrête de
brûler qu'on arrête de la regarder
brûler et la deuxième question elle est
pour vous aurélien pradié vous êtes
secrétaire général des républicains
qu'est ce qu'on peut faire pour qu'enfin
l'écologie soit au centre de nos débats
pour que la droite de 2021 soit verte et
que la france de 2022 serait durable
merci beaucoup merci
alors je vous propose florian sur cette
question essentielle des importations ça
a été évoqué hier c'est évoquer
aujourd'hui dans nos discussions
comment un chef d'entreprise vie cette
question là quelles sont les limites
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire qu'est ce que
vous faites
qu'est-ce que tu tentes de faire pour
conformer des paroles et des actes sur
un sujet aussi essentiel et puis on
passa la parole a admis ensuite notre
vie en tant que patron d'entreprise
c'est de sauter des barrières donc
chaque fois qu à une barrière ont la
cote et ceux qui veulent les contourner
c'est de les contourner donkey entre
guillemets rien à faire et j'ai envie de
dire que je vous pose la question parce
qu'en fait c'est aux politiques de
définir la normalisation de ce que l'on
veut importer avoir en france peut avoir
en france en europe ou à travers le
monde et moi aujourd'hui je subis et je
suis positivement dans le sens où je
trouve toujours des moyens de me
différencier pour apporter de la valeur
ajoutée sur un marché je dirais par
rapport à ce sujet la sq étroite
corrélation la france un des plus beaux
modèles agroalimentaire au monde et elle
s'attache tous les jours à le détruire
et les médias y contribue également dès
lors qu'à une petite crise qui vient de
provoquer le décès de un ou deux bébés
alors que dans le monde entier des gens
meurent soit parce qu'ils n'ont pas
d'alimentation peut soit parce que le
système alimentaire n'est pas fiable
comme nous l'avons construit en france
et de ce fait nous avons perdu l'aura
que la france à travers travers le monde
notamment pour aider à construire en
chine en afrique en inde et aux états
unis soit le nouveau modèle alimentaire
je parle des états unis soit un modèle
alimentaire durable pérenne et qui
permet de nourrir tout le monde et là je
parle plutôt de l'hémisphère sud
et de deux
et de la chine et ça c'est un drame
parce que l'allemagne est passée devant
nous l'italie passer devant nous en
termes d'exportation à la fois de
marchandises est à la fois de savoir
faire deuxième manche j'ai une vision
très européenne du sujet je ne crois pas
à une france agricole je crois à une
europe agricole c'est la diversité et la
richesse des terroirs qui nous permet
d'avoir une accès à une alimentation
aussi riche aussi diversifiée donc aussi
nutritionnellement bonne et je suis
favorable à la défense d'une d'une
agriculture européenne qui a été
totalement balayé ces cinq dernières
années
l'agriculture c'est le fondement d'une
société c'est le fondement d'une nation
un général de gaulle 1962 c'est la base
de la pyramide de maslow si on veut
éviter tout problème de société on l'a
bien vu la pression que nous avons eu au
mois de mars
au niveau étatique sur nous entends
filières alimentaires agricoles et de
distribution qui était de dire au début
on s'est concentré sur les hôpitaux et
en fait on a compris que le premier
problème pouvait être l'axé enfin le
manque d'accès à l'alimentation est donc
tout ce que ça pouvait provoquer en
termes de de folie humaine pour aller se
nourrir et c'est bien normal puisque
c'est un besoin vital et est donc cette
europe a besoin de s'unifier et elle a
surtout besoin de renouer avec son
schéma historique qui était la
régulation de son marché intérieur et
non plus la libéralisation de matières
premières agricoles qui nous amène à
produire plus et ça je le vois dans mon
quotidien a un coup de moins en moins
élevé donc ça n'a aucun sens économique
ça n'a aucun sens écologique ça aucun
intérêt et vous l'avait bien dit tout à
l'heure lors de l'autre débat ça vient
amener un déséquilibre de notre balance
commerciale qui est dramatique et qui
inquiète en tout cas quand on voit quels
pourraient être les autres crises à
venir les dix prochaines années
et donc je suis favorable à ce que
l'europe se réunissent autour d'une
alimentation et d'une politique
d'alimentation qui englobera de fait les
enjeux agricoles les enjeux sociaux les
enjeux environnementaux les enjeux
sanitaires et qui lui permettra du coup
de nous assurer durablement un accès à
une alimentation saine responsable et
accessible parce que la notion de prix
compte également des biens sur cette
question de l'enjeu politique de
l'écologie ce la france que l'on veut
c'est pas une france verte c'est une
france bleu ont fait une france
tricolore en tous les cas pour les
années qui viennent mais comment est-ce
que notre famille politique replace ce
sujet là ok
lors du débat sans se fourvoyer sans se
perdre mais en retrouvant aussi
l'intérêt de nos concitoyens
oui je crois que c'est essentiel que
notre famille politique se saisissent de
ce sujet à part entière sans tabou et en
apportant bien toutes les innovations
importantes je crois par exemple et je
le dis sous le contrôle et en saluant
notre président du sénat gérard larcher
le président du groupe bruno retailleau
qui viennent d'arriver que je crois
justement une écologie par le progrès et
aussi par l'innovation
l'écologie n'est pas antinomique avec la
question d'innovation on a des débats
actuellement très important par exemple
sur la 4g sur la 5 g sur les évolutions
numériques je crois que notre famille
politique dans le lever c'est tabou là
je voudrais répondre à la question qui a
été qui a été posé sur la question
finalement des importations et de la
manière dont on doit pouvoir gérer au
niveau européen ce que le partage d'un
train thalys que ça se faire au niveau
européen cela on avait une proposition
et ont apporté une proposition pendant
la campagne européenne avec
françois-xavier bellamy cette
proposition c'était ce qu'on appelle la
création la mise en place d'une barrière
écologique l'arrière écologique ça veut
dire quoi ça veut dire des droits de
douane antipollution ça veut dire que
quand on a des produits qui sont
importées sur le territoire européen qui
son émetteur tout simplement de co2 eh
bien il puisse y avoir justement cette
taxe à l'importation au niveau de la
frontière européenne pour tout
simplement et bien valoriser nos
produits locaux valoriser nos circuits
courts et valoriser notre économie de
proximité
7 cette proposition elle me semble juste
elle me semble toujours d'actualité
parce que c'est le commerce équitable
parce que c'est la manière tout
simplement d'éviter le dumping
environnemental malheureusement qu'on
constate tous les jours au niveau
européen et parce que c'est un enjeu
majeur bien sûr pour nous et pour la
société française donne juste ce chiffre
chaque année chaque année 2 milliards de
tonnes de co2 sont importés sur le
territoire européen ce qui vous montre
l'importance et que si on faisait juste
et bien un petit calcul et qu'on faisait
cette barrière écologique avait été
proposée par la droite
à l'époque eh bien s'ils ont décidé de
cet axe aux importations de cette
barrière là à 27 euros par exemple la
tonne en or et 50 milliards d'euros par
an pour justement mener des politiques
importantes
je le dis parce que souvent dans notre
vision de l'écologie
moi je suis de ceux qui pensent qu'il ne
faut pas aller sur le terrain de la
fiscalité punitive de celle qui
sanctionne qui sanctionne les
comportements qui déresponsabilise et
qui en fait infantilise tout le monde
pourquoi parce que n'oublions jamais
n'oublions jamais que le mouvement des
gilet jaune
il est né aussi à un moment donné d'une
volonté d'augmenter la taxe carbone est
d'augmenter la fiscalité en fait sur les
carburants et donc si on veut entraîner
un mouvement favorable pour nous et si
on veut réconcilier écologie et économie
et répondre à cette question très
importante de l'indépendance alimentaire
alors oui cette proposition que nous
avions fait pendant cette campagne
européenne sur une barrière écologique à
l'entrée me semble répondre à un certain
nombre de choses et puis il faudra
effectivement construire les conditions
de notre indépendance alimentaire
vous savez l'europe elle est née sur un
triptyque pain paix liberté et dans ce
triptyque paix liberté il ya le mot pain
et le bon pain ça veut dire quoi ça veut
dire l'indépendance alimentaire
alors moi j'ai pas envie j'ai pas envie
que demain parce que on serait victime
justement de ce dumping environnemental
au ce2 ce dumping social par rapport à
d'autres pays hors de l'union européenne
qu'on soit en situation de dépendance
alimentaire qu'on dépendent du reste du
monde
alors que toute la construction
européenne a été justement d'assurer la
subsistance alimentaire à l'ensemble des
peuples européens
c'est un beau défi c'est un bel
engagement et sans montre tout
simplement que souvent les premiers
écologistes en france ce sont les
agriculteurs et que plutôt que d opposer
il faut les rassembler et les porter
haut et fort
merci beaucoup je pense qu'on passe un
peu à droite parce qu'on a été beaucoup
à gauche je trouve depuis tout à l'heure
bonjour bonjour l'hydraulique berne et
de la région sud provence alpes côte
d'azur
félicitations aussi beau que l'occitane
presque juste un constat un exemple et
une question on constate tout à l'heure
damien bad vous avez dit personne n'a le
monopole de l'optimisme je rajouterais
que personne ne doit avoir le monopole
de la protection de l'environnement est
aujourd'hui dans le débat public c'est
vrai qu'on a l'impression que pour
s'occuper la préservation de
l'environnement
il faudrait qu'on adhère un parti
politique qui est en réalité prend un
thème et on fait le seul sujet en
réalité derrière c'est un rassemblement
on l'a très bien vu à marseille
notamment un rassemblement
d'apparatchiks socialistes qui ont
essayé de se redorer tout simplement la
pilule en se donnant l'étiquette
d'écologistes or derrière cette écologie
elle et punitive
cette écologie elle est dogmatique cette
idée est cette écologie elle est
idéologique
par exemple je vous donne un exemple
très simple sur la région pendant 30 ans
ce sont les socialistes les écologistes
et les communistes qui ont gouverné à la
destinée de cette région et pour autant
c'est sous l'impulsion de renaud
muselier que depuis ces six dernières
années on a fait plus qu'en trente ans
de la gauche l'écologie c'est 500
millions d'euros qui ont été investis
pour la préservation de l'environnement
c'est la méditerranée du futur qui a été
créée pour rassembler les pays de la
méditerranée sur la protection de
l'environnement c'est la droite qui l'a
fait et la droite ne doit pas avoir peur
de le dire
et donc ma question très simplement sur
ses actions territoriales sur ces
actions qui sont faits chaque jour par
les maires de france et l'eire et du
centre chaque jour par les présidents de
départements chaque jour par les
présidents de région comment pouvons
nous remonter ses actions au niveau
national je vous remercie beaucoup pour
cet enthousiasme que
que nous partageons on va se prendre une
seconde question allez-y vous voulez
choisissez celui qui vous convient le
mieux
bonjour je m'appelle brain si elle skie
et je suis en école d'ingénieurs à lyon
et on a rappelé donc l'étymologie du mot
écologie et sa part de logos donc de
science cette reconnaissance est
aujourd'hui donc on constate que
l'écologie est beaucoup devenu
dogmatique médiatique et sentimentale
alors que la part de sciences a été un
petit peu mise mise de côté notamment
avec le bashing nucléaire etc
et donc ma question est la suivante
comment remettre la science au coeur de
l'écologie parce que je n'imagine pas
une croissance et donc le progrès sans
la science il vous remercie
merci beaucoup sur ces deux questions se
posent de passer la parole à à sophie
sur la question notamment des acteurs
locaux de ce que nous faisons en réalité
déjà depuis de nombreuses années les uns
les autres et notamment les acteurs
territoriaux sur la question de la
préservation de l'environnement
une simple parenthèse ce qui se passe
déjà là aujourd'hui c'est un signe voyez
parmi toutes les tables rondes que
christian jacob a à proposer il y en a
une qui est consacrée à la question de
l'écologie et de la croissance c'est
déjà un vrai signe et c'est le début
d'une réflexion qu'il nous faut
poursuivre je pense que les uns et les
autres peut être fier notamment des
échanges que nous avons aujourd'hui qui
sont déjà un véritable message politique
que nous voulons à la fois vous adresser
mais aussi adressé aux français
sophie tu élu local sur sur cette
question-là d'action locale de la
manière dont on les valorise
est ce que tu peux nous en dire quelques
mots oui et je te remercie pour ta
question parce que la crise du coc vide
nous a projeté à analyser le triptyque
dans lequel on fait partie et je rejoins
la poupe le propos du dirigeant parce
qu'on est à la fois citoyen avec une
conscience écologique à la fois
consommateur alors parfois schizophrène
dans nos comportements et à la fois
engagée dans une action
public et qui mérite d'être valorisé et
comment on peut faire remonter tout ça
parce que le lien entre l'écologie
positive celle qui amène le citoyen
consommateur contribue elle aussi
parfois et bien avoir cette démarche
transversale que vous évoquez et bien
c'est en créant du lien et ce lien là
c'est pas depuis des grands débats qui
manque parfois de pragmatisme qu'on le
vit c'est ce que vous faites ce que nous
faisons dans les régions dans les
mairies dans les départements et nous le
faisons largement et depuis très
longtemps et le grand débat excusez moi
mais ce fameux tour de france qui aurait
dû permettre de faire remonter ce que
nous faisons des propositions et de les
transformer et ses salles celle de la
politique en véritable politique
publique et bien n'a pas abouti sur ces
questions et ce sont les régions
aujourd'hui chères renault et merci du
travail que tu fais à régions de france
avec l'ensemble de chacun des
territoires qui vont mobiliser des fonds
et les régions vont aller encore plus
loin parce que le plan de relance
européen le plan d'investissement cité
les propos de françois xavier bellamy
sont une opportunité progrès et vous
l'avez tire bien dit le progrès avec une
chaîne de valeur une chaîne de valeurs
humanistes c'est à dire des
investissements que porte la france que
portent les régions que portait
territoire et qui vont servir des
projets précis et je crois beaucoup dans
ce que tu dis c'est que plus nous serons
en capacité à démontrer à participer de
façon pragmatique à des projets
d'environnement et de développement
durable ce que nous ont plu nous
arrivons à amener les citoyens dans un
comportement durable responsables
permanents mais c'est très important et
on voit bien le côté très centralisateur
actuellement de notre gouvernement sur
ces questions qui parfois même sur des
expérimentations parce que
l'expérimentation c'est ce que nous
avons dit hier lors de la table ronde
nous permet de déployer des politiques
publiques quand nous faisons en région
normandie d'exaspérer mentation sur les
semences
quand nous permettons à des start-up de
venir se greffer à des projets
d'environnement de grandes sociétés
françaises qui font aussi notre
notoriété au niveau européen et mondial
eh bien nous sommes au service de la
cause durable donc c'est cela que nous
devons porter
mille fois merci pour ta question et
vous pouvez compter sur nous et régions
de france pour dans le cadre du plan
d'avenir porter haut et fort les
couleurs des territoires cher président
du sénat florian peut-être sur la
question sûrement sur la question
l'innovation peut souvent s'interroger
en disant est ce que cette question
environnementale
cette conscience environnementale n'est
pas un frein au développement économique
est ce que dans une entreprise comme
andros dont l'objectif est de maintenir
ces emplois être développées
économiquement la structure est ce que
c'est un frein ou est-ce que ça peut
être comme le disait le président chirac
eu à l'époque d'ailleurs une formidable
source de conquête
la nouvelle pour notre société mais
aussi de conquête économique clairement
et j'ai juste ajouter quelque chose en
tant que client finalement de la
politique locale et des territoires
clairement pour dire qu'aujourd'hui avec
mes 18 du bij et 18 usines en france je
suis dans 15 départements et je peux
vous assurer que non seulement nous
sommes des acteurs de revitalisation des
territoires avec des écosystèmes que
nous créons autour de nous mais surtout
que jamais nous n'avons eu autant de
soutiens locaux départementaux et
régionaux pour essayer de nous
développer ça c'est une bonne nouvelle
en tout cas ce que je crois que la
décentralisation et la diversité que
l'on a dans les territoires et notamment
les territoires ruraux dieu sait que
dans le nord du lot n'y a pas grand
chose à part andros et ses 2500 salariés
et 6000 emplois indirects derrière et
ben finalement on génère des écosystèmes
économies qui sont extrêmement rentables
avec des gens heureux des niveaux de vie
qui sont bien plus élevé que celui que
vous pouvez avoir quand vous habitez à
paris et c'est un peu les modèles
auvergnat c'est à dire on se partage
l'argent entre nous tous mais in fine et
finalement c'est plus de 100 120
millions d'euros qui tourne en économie
constante et qui alimente des systèmes
économiques locaux auxquelles je crois
énormément c'est là permet de dominer
vous pouvez y travailler le sujet
d'innovation et du développement et les
clés pour nous c'est une opportunité
c'est une chance extraordinaire et j'ai
envie dire on a même pas besoin de tête
des états ou des régions pour le faire
puisque toute façon c'est notre raison
d'exister si nous ne prenons pas ce
virage là le consommateur nous écarte de
ses choix
conclusion nous innovons pour lui pour
ce progrès là et nous le faisons en
créant plus de valeur et on y trouve
surtout un intérêt et c'est là où je
voudrais conclure un petit peu cette
logique je pense que on a tous su y
compris dans le monde des entreprises
des visions très mono centre et c'est un
petit peu le problème du parti politique
entre guillemets comme du patron
d'entreprise c'est de fixer un cap selon
un indicateur
soit c'est l'actionnaire soit c'est le
collaborateur soit c'est le client soit
c'est ainsi de suite et le monde dans
lequel on est rentrés depuis 2000 et
notamment grâce au développement du
numérique vous oblige à avoir une vision
multicentrique ça vous rappelle les
mauvais souvenir puisque la dernière
élection a été gagnée dans une logique
multicentrique et c'est bien le multi
centrisme aujourd'hui qui règne au sein
de mon entreprise en tout cas et qui va
régner comme règle de gestion des
écosystèmes économiques sociaux et
environnementaux
parce qu'on ne peut plus avoir que
l'actionnaire en tête et la finance on
doit avoir l'ensemble des acteurs de
l'écosystème
ça vaut pour une entreprise je pense que
ça vaut également pour la gestion d'un
territoire d'un département et donc oui
l'innovation est source de progrès oui
le progrès et peut être vers entre
guillemets même si j'aime pas ce mot là
et naturellement on ne sait même plus
une question de soutien et de support
c'est une question de volonté et je
pense que vous devez nous l'impulser
quand on la porte qu'on est jeune qu'on
a des salariés qu'ils la comprennent ça
va très vite
le seul frein que je mettrais c'est la
distorsion entre notre rythme a le
rythme de l'entreprise et des marchés et
ce d'autant plus pour une entreprise que
je ne qualifie pas nous ne sommes pas
une entreprise internationale même si je
suis présent dans 25 pays à travers le
monde
je suis une entreprise multi local donc
je construis des systèmes économiques
locaux pour nourrir des populations
locales et donc cette logique la multi
local vaut aussi pour la
décentralisation de la france je crois
et la gestion européenne où l'algue
verte à l'heure et est donc je voulais
dire par là que vous avez cette logique
un peu de de construire à travers un
centre de pensées et d'idées des
écosystèmes à travers le monde qui
répondent à des enjeux globaux et bien
sûr quand je suis en afrique en côte
d'ivoire en inde actuellement je
construis une usine dans le shandong en
chine ou aux états unis ont construit la
troisième usine d'andros c'est pas du
tout les mêmes enjeux on parle pas du
tout dé même thématique
en revanche on intègre l'ensemble de
l'écosystème et à la fin on génère plus
de valeur donc de la croissance de la
profitabilité de l'emploi et avec tout
ça puisque en 2025 nous seront neutres
en carbone avec la neutralité carbone
derrière donc oui la réconciliation
l'alliance des deux est tout à fait
possible c'est une question de volonté
c'est une question de dogme c'est une
question de bifurcation de modèles de
pensée par rapport au pib à la
croissance qui a été installé il suffit
d'être humain de croire en sa maison et
de vouloir développer sa maison
correctement
merci beaucoup damien quelques mots sur
ces enjeux notamment de l'innovation et
de la science qui qui est que un mot
presque devenu imprononçable aujourd'hui
alors qu'il a il a permis le progrès ben
oui complètement et je partage
totalement ce qui ce qui vient d'être
dit je pense que effectivement le
progrès et l'innovation la science sont
vecteurs aussi et bien d'une meilleure
d'une planète plus verte ou en tout cas
plus respectueuse et et protectrice de
l'environnement et et on le voit tous
les jours et on le constate au quotidien
moi je crois à cette écologie comme l'a
dit sophie de l'enracinement et des
territoires
je crois que vous avez bien fait de le
rappeler tout à l'heure parce que nous
avons de nombreux maires de nombreux
présidents département de nombreux
présidents de région de nombreux élus
qui au quotidien mènent de véritables
politiques écologiques environnementales
qui sont positives et la marque de
fabrique notre mouvement c'est que cette
politique elle se construit sur la
concertation et elle se construit sur
les changes et non pas par le dogme ou
par l'idéologie et je crois que c'est
une grande différence et on le sait au
quotidien on peut faire beaucoup de
choses
enfin ce contrôle d'eric ciotti qui
comme moi étaient présentes département
on à la politique des espaces naturels
sensibles
il ya la question de la gestion de l'eau
la réaction des ressources bien entendu
au niveau des régions également on a
beaucoup de compétences pour agir
justement sur y compris sur la politique
énergétique et donc c'est cette écologie
là au concret et les différences on les
constate tous les jours
la différence entre un maire qui se dit
écolo de l'écologie punitive
ben c'est celui par exemple comme à lyon
qui va interdire le survol de la
patrouille de france pour des raisons
écologistes c'est celui qui à rennes va
interdire le passage du tour de france
et dans le même temps on va faire la
promotion du vélo contre la voiture
c'est celui qui à paris interdit un
certain nombre de voitures qui t'a créé
des bouchons des embouteillages à
déporter la popul la pollution sur les
territoires périurbains et ruraux
eh bien c'est exactement ce que nous ne
voulons pas nous voulons une écologie
l'enracinement des territoires
respectueuse de tout le monde et que
l'on vive dans un village que l'on vive
dans ce qu'on soit habitants d'une
une grande métropole ou d'un territoire
pire urbain on a droit tous à respirer
le bon air
on aura tous tout simplement à avoir une
nature et un protection de
l'environnement qui sera meilleur
merci d'amiens on va continuer nos
échanges
alors je vois au bout de mon doigt donc
c'est ma gauche mais c'est votre droite
comme quoi tout est relatif allez-y
vas-y bonjour bonjour donc je m'appelle
et loisy et je viens de doux et
corrections les pour vous rien pradier
elle porte sur les transports dont vous
êtes député d'une grande circonscription
géographiquement dans le lot qui est un
département où sortie de cahors c'est
très compliqué de vivre sans voiture
donc je vais vous demander ce que votre
vision pour l'avenir du lot dans le
transport qu'est ce que vous voulez
faire pour avoir des transports
écologiques mais qui permettent de
dynamiser vos territoires
merci beaucoup et c'est un enjeu qui
concerne beaucoup de territoires ruraux
on va prendre une deuxième et une
troisième question s'il vous plaît oui
bah dis donc je vais plutôt m'adresser à
damien abad donc bonjour monsieur donc
je m'appelle adhémar lamoureux je suis
chasseur et fils d'agriculteur dans
l'oise et j'aurais aimé connaître votre
position sur la chasse
[Musique]
donc willi scholl président de la
fédération des chasseurs a10 le chasseur
est le premier écologiste de france et
je le soutiens donc j'aurais aimé savoir
votre position si vous soutenez ou non
la chasse et si oui ne signez pas le rip
camp avec les animalistes et les
antispécistes merci beaucoup
[Musique]
alors s'il vous plaît à votre droite
oui on fait remarquer qu'il y a peu de
filles qui posent des questions alors
peut-être que je ne vois pas en fait
vas-y manger après donc moi je m'adresse
à la première vice présidente de
république à qui est aussi en charge de
l'écologie et de l'économie
ma question est la suivante c'est
rejoint un petit peu dans le sur la
thématique du transport normandie vous
est le fleuron la deuxième région sur la
thématique de l'hydrogène et je vous en
félicite parce que je suis on va
inactifs et moi je m'adresse aussi à
gérard larcher à bruno retailleau à
damien abad parce que c'est vraiment
aussi à eux qu'il avance
je suis positionné sur une candidature
dans le sport mais terne d'automobiles
et fleuron aussi avec le cirque ou
ronron les et ça ma question est la
suivante si on détruit le sport
automobile qui est aussi un moyen
d'innovations et de la mobilité
comment à l'échelle d'un territoire vous
pouvez sur la normandie mais à l'échelle
internationale de la france démontré
parce que sans nom sans le sport
automobile
on peut pas développer une nouvelle
mobilité donc je m'adresse à vous madame
la présidente et à monsieur abattre
principalement d'un point du je dirais
législatif comment vous pouvez le vrai
protégé à cette nouvelle mobilité et de
protéger le sport automobile ont
malencontreusement pendant huit ans elle
a fait des heat
ils font absolument rien et c'est
totalement bleu
merci beaucoup on voit les questions sur
les transports je propose qu'on prenne
une autre question à une implication sur
les chasseurs sur les transports
répondre collectivement je vous en prie
à l'isi merci beaucoup tout d'abord je
voulais faire un constat il ya une sorte
d'auto flagellation en france sur
surtout sur l'identité sur l'histoire et
notamment sur les efforts que nous
faisons je pense que la france est quand
même l'un des pays pieds pionner en
termes d'environnement et d'écologie et
je pense que peut-être je fais un damon
est ce qu'on n'a pas aussi aider à
l'émergence parce qu'on sait pas on n'a
pas été assez audacieux pas mis assez de
volonté au niveau de l'écologie pour
faire aujourd'hui qu'ils aient une
certaine divergence entre guillemets de
des partis écologiques voilà est
question plutôt sur l'énergie sur le
nucléaire et la fermeture récemment de
lusine à un pardon de la centrale
nucléaire de fessenheim
qu'est ce que vous en pensez et surtout
ça veut dire quoi en gros est ce que ça
veut dire que nous allons vers une
décolonisation de la france en termes dé
l'énergie
c'est quoi notre projet aujourd'hui
alors que le nucléaire est quand même la
principale source de notre énergie est
ce que demain il ya c-zéro nucléaire et
quels sont les quels sont les autres
ressources que nous pourrons utiliser
merci merci beaucoup on va prendre les
uns les autres la parole pour répondre à
ces questions si j'essaie de les résumer
on a une question centrale qui est
comment faire en sorte au fond qu'on
puisse se poser la question la
préservation de l'environnement sans
sacrifier ceux qui aujourd'hui fait
notre mode de vie nos éléments de
culture je pense à la chasse et des
éléments fondamentaux qui sont ceux des
transports
il ya une réalité c'est vrai dans
beaucoup de départements ruraux c'est
vrai dans le département du lot
aujourd'hui le transport en commun dans
le département du lot il se limitait la
ville de cahors et la ville de figeac
puis ailleurs il faut prendre sa voiture
parfois il faut avoir deux voitures même
pour pouvoir aller travailler et on n'a
pas d'autre solution que celle ci mais
on voit bien les uns et les autres à
quel point sur cette question de
l'écologie
on a tendance à nous enfermer sur des
sujets qui à mon sens ce sont plutôt des
micros au sujet en vérité qui sont pas
les sujets fondamentaux et tout ça pour
éviter de se poser des questions plus
transversale de transformation du modèle
plus globalement donc je vais laisser la
parole aux différents intervenants sur
la question des transports sur la
question de la chasse damien peut-être
pour pour commencer et puis ensuite
sophie florian et puis celles et ceux
qui veulent prendre la parole sur les
autres enjeux notamment leur jeu de
l'énergie oui tout à fait j'essaie
d'apporter une réponse globale
tu as raison je crois que de temps en
temps on a tendance à nous vouloir nous
enfermer pour nous caricaturer surnombre
dessus sur un certain nombre de sujets
et sur lequel nous devons effectivement
être particulièrement vigilants sur la
question des transports et des
infrastructures
d'abord nous devons et nous devons
continuer et poursuivre à avoir des
grands projets d'infrastructures en
france et d'ailleurs il faut qu'on soit
très clair si demain on veut une
politique propre des transports si on
veut développer le fret
eh bien il nous faudra envisager ses
infrastructures et ses projets là qui
sont très importants et donc ce qu'on
appelle les autoroutes du fret ou autres
seront fondamentales donc dans le
transport il faut effectivement
désenclaver nos territoires
il faut faire en sorte que le transport
en commun soit accessible par tous
partout c'est un travail bien sûr de
longue haleine d'où le fait
d'où le fait de préserver nos villes
moyennes moi je crois beaucoup à la
capacité des villes moyennes haïk à
irriguer un territoire autour de lui et
à éviter justement cette fracture
territoriale parce que si demain on vous
dit comme on l'entend ici
eh bien écoutez vous n'avez plus le
droit de prendre votre voiture ou alors
si vous allez apprendre on va vous taxer
votre carburant parce que c'est pas bien
ce que vous faites
mais dans le même temps vous mettez pas
les transports en commun qui vont avec
alors vous êtes justement dans cette
écologie punitive que nous ne voulons
pas et donc l'enjeu c'est de construire
cette politique de transports en commun
médecins opposés les uns aux autres il
peut y avoir des voies sur berge il peut
y avoir des vélos des trottinettes des
voitures tout ceci doit pouvoir se
coordonner en tant que tel il nous faut
travailler à cette politique de
transport c'est une notamment avec les
régions bien entendu c'est essentiel et
je crois qu'on peut avancer là dessus
avant de dire un mot sur sur la chasse
le dire un mot super mais sur la
question du nucléaire qui est une
question centrale est là qui a été posé
sur la dénucléarisation ou pas de notre
pays
d'abord il faut qu'on soit clair pour le
sous contrôle de raphaël mais à toutes
celles et tous ceux qui disent que
finalement le nucléaire ce responsable
de tous nos maux
n'oublions jamais que l'énergie
nucléaire est l'énergie décarbonée par
excellence et que si demain nous
abandonnons nucléaire abandonné le
nucléaire dénucléarisé la société
française c'est recart bonnet le
territoire français parce que la réalité
et regardons les choses en face
enfin on a toujours ce débat sur
nucléaire éolien photovoltaïque tout ça
est très important bien entendu mais
quand vous regardez la consommation
c'est un débat sur la transition
électrique cantournet de la consommation
énergétique finale vous rendez compte
qu'en fait des vrais sujets ce sont
notamment le pétrole le gaz ou le
charbon est que en gros ce que on les
verts appellent parfois une transition
énergétique
non en fait c'est par idéologie ils font
une transition électrique en voulant
nous faire sortir du nucléaire là où
nous avons un avantage comparatif qui
est l'économie la plus décarbonés qui
permet d'avoir des factures
d'électricité qui restent encore
relativement basses par rapport aux
autres pays européens
mais est-ce que si vous voulez les
gilets verts juste après les gilet jaune
est bien effectivement il faut sortir du
nucléaire
et là on aura des conséquences
économiques et sociales dramatiques et
bien face à ça on doit construire
linverse et cet enjeu il est fondamental
et ses débats sur la part du nucléaire
dans le mix énergétique g trouve
toujours un peu sur surréaliste et est
donc je pense qu'il faut clairement dire
que nous avons besoin de cette énergie
nucléaire et que l'un n'empêche pas de
développer les énergies renouvelables
loin s'en faut
et enfin parce que l'heure tourne un mot
sur la chasse va faire attention à ce
que je dis parce que j'ai quand même
d'aider des chefs et des spécialistes
devant au premier rang mais soyons très
clairs
d'abord pour je vais vous répondre
franchement ce rip ce référendum
d'initiative partagée comme vous l'avez
rappelé non seulement moi je ne le
signerai pas nous avons eu le débat en
groupe et notre groupe ne signe pas ce
référendum qui s'étaient partagés
mais pourquoi parce que moi je n'accepte
pas que l'on jette au pilori une
catégorie de français et je vais y
revenir sur le rôle de la chasse mais je
le dis aussi avec la même vigueur
c'est pas parce qu'on signe pas le rip
qu'on doit pas faire des efforts et
c'est pas parce qu'on signe pas le
rythme qu'on doit pas poser la question
du bien-être animal
nous à droite et si j'ai un message et
un conseil à vous donner
saisissons nous de ce sujet ne soyons
pas simplement dans la défensive
ne soyons pas simplement dans celles et
ceux qui veulent protéger une activité
qui est fondamentale mais soyons aussi
acteurs du mouvement de demain et je
voulais si nous ne le faisons pas alors
les autres le feront avec toutes les
conséquences dramatiques que ça aura sur
la chasse mais sur aussi plein d'autres
activités et donc nous devons aussi à
droite
poser la question du bien-être animal
évoluer sur un stand de choses et
surtout je le dis on oublie souvent moi
je savais je suis né en camargue
alors quand on est né en camargue la
chasse on sait à quel point ça participe
à la biodiversité du système et on sait
à khar à quel point ça participe à la
diversification tout simplement des
espèces et je le sais comme vous
s'il n'y avait pas eu en camargue et
s'il n'ya pas en camargue comme ailleurs
en france des chasseurs on n'aurait pas
la richesse et la biodiversité que nous
avons aujourd'hui dans cette zone humide
et il faut aussi le rappeler à celles et
ceux qui veulent stigmatiser
cet homme de personnes et même chose sur
le sport automobile et j'en conclus par
là mais je suis peut-être mal placé mais
enfin j'étais de faire un peu de pub
mois il se trouve que je suis allé une
fois au trophée andros et au trophée
andros
j'ai découvert quelque chose c'est que
on peut faire du sport automobile et
aller vers une voie écologique et j'ai
découvert une course avec des voitures
électriques je le dis aussi là dessus
développons l'électrique développons
l'hydrogène mais soyons aussi très
concret aujourd'hui on parle on est
beaucoup axé sur les moteurs mais
personne sait par exemple que dans le
les freins et que la pollution sur les
freins des voitures est beaucoup plus
importante que celle des moteurs
on n'en parle pas parce que c'est pas
des émissions de co2
sauf que c'est des émissions de
particules fines et que c'était tout
aussi grave
alors à nous aussi plutôt que de
supprimer les voitures et le sport
automobile de construire la route
durable de réduire la pollution des
moteurs et des freins et en même temps
d'avoir une vie meilleure pour tous
c'est ça que nous devons porter comme
message à droite merci la vie un florian
la transition est toute faite notamment
avec le trophée andros est peut-être une
un point sur la question des transports
lisez tout à l'heure mais tu es
implantées dans des zones extrêmement
rural la plupart du temps et la question
de la mobilité pour les collaborateurs
d'un groupe comme le tien est une
question essentielle fondamentale oui
donc merci pour la publicité sur le
trophée andros vous ne connaissez à
travers nos marques andros bonne maman
mamie nova évidemment et en 1989
l'entreprise a créé la première course
de voitures sur glace au monde et en
2004 elles celles fixées le pari de
rendre cette course électrique d'abord
avec des voitures de deux roues
électriques donc ça a été des gros
investissements français d'un
confiturier de quelqu'un qui récolte les
fruits qui essaient de faire la
confiture et qui nous a permis en 2011
d'arrivée avec les premières formules
eux qui ont existé au monde et qui avait
défilé sur le circuit du mans si vous
rappeler c'était la seule course qui a
été autorisé et on voulait faire le tour
de de paris et de la concorde mais ça a
été interdite et en 2017 nous avons créé
les premières voitures électriques 4
roues motrices au monde
dans le lot non là on s'amuse avec une
petite entreprise et je reviens du coup
un autre lot qui nous est si cher pour
vous dire que on n'a aucune raison
d'être là bas si ce n'est d'être né
là-bas en 1950 et d'avoir des fruits à
l'époque nous permettait à travers le
fret notamment ont seulement de recevoir
du sucre mais ensuite d'expédier des
produits finis se ferait a disparu dans
les années 1980 et depuis l'entreprise
se bat pour essayer de se connecter à
l'autoroute qui est à une heure et demie
d'elle à peu près pour éviter que à peu
près 180 camions par jour traversent
dans les villages où il y a à la fois
des écoles et qui détruisent les routes
donc il faut les reconstruire tous les
cinq ans à peu près ainsi de suite l
entreprise a une idée géniale en 2011
c'est d'inventer non pas le train
électrique mais le wagon électrique le
wagon autoporteur électrique et on s'est
retrouvé face à la fois au syndicalisme
du fret et
également sa lenteur et notre projet a
toujours été refusé alors que nous
disposons aujourd'hui d'automotive
électriques qui sont extrêmement légères
entre guillemets donc il n'y a pas
besoin de rétablir les voix comme on
nous l'avait dit avec les centaines de
millions d'euros qui nous permettent de
faire transiter sur les voies de biars
ca brive de brive vers toulouse de brive
vers orléans dès que les containers
entiers puisque nous vendons des 240
mille tonnes de produits qui sortent de
cette usine donc j'ai autant de matière
première en trente autant de matières
premières sortante et finalement on n'y
arrive pas donc c'est un sujet qu'on a
remis auprès de la région aujourd'hui
puisqu'on voit bien qu'il ya un
renouveau du fret
et sachez en tout cas que nous avons la
solution technique aujourd'hui qui
n'existe pas aniche heures c'est l'heure
ni ailleurs qui permet d'avoir des
automotive indépendante électrique et
qui avec la pente et la notion du
freinage notamment se recharge et permet
du coup d'avoir un bilan qui est
extrêmement neutre pour transporter des
containers comme on veut en france il
suffit de redensifier un petit peu le
réseau pour y arriver
merci florian je vous propose de prendre
une dernière question avant que nous
soyons obligés de conclure et j'ai fait
une promesse dont je vais tâcher de la
tenir
mademoiselle vous aurez la dernière
question et on sera ensuite au temps de
la conclusion on aura l'occasion
d'échanger tout au long de la journée
mais il faut qu'on puisse tenir à peu
près la taille mais je vous en prie
merci bonjour à tous sonia charette du
val de marne joinville aise alors moi
j'ai envie de parler dont un sujet qui a
effleuré monsieur abad donc la pollution
j'ai envie de parler de la durite
écologie croissance de ce que subissent
donc les banlieues parisiennes à cause
de la politique de madame hidalgo
répercussions frappante avec une
augmentation de la pollution 2 1 + 1 à
5% sur les grands axes parisiens et donc
ma question est comment assurer une
politique dite écologique comme celle
des algues au à paris et la continuité
de la croissance économique de la région
merci beaucoup je vais laisser la parole
à adhamiyah pour pour y répondre
c'est un des aspects essentiels qu'on a
qu'on a touché du doigt la question
environnementale doit pas être une
nouvelle source d'injustice au fond si
demain celles et ceux qui seront
préservés sur des questions de pollution
l'air d'accès à une nutrition de qualité
sont seulement seulement celles et ceux
qui en ont les moyens on aura créé une
bhl injustice inacceptable et sur la
question d'alimentation on le voit de
manière flagrante aujourd'hui celles et
ceux qui ont accès à une alimentation
la moins bonne qualité notamment du fait
de la course aux prix et freiner ce sont
celles et ceux qui ont le moins de
moyens et donc on rajoute à des
injustices sociales
d'autres injustices insupportables qui
serait celle de bénéficier d'un
environnement de plus ou moins bonne
qualité et d'une alimentation de plus ou
moins bonne qualité
damiano disais tout à l'heure et
politiques écologistes qui sont menées
dans certaines villes pousse à cela au
fond une écologie pour les beaux
quartiers
et puis ce sont les autres les
périphériques qui paieront l'addition et
c'est tout à fait insupportable à l'idée
que nous nous faisons de la société de
la justice sociale et sûrement de l'idée
même de la politique damien quelques
mots et puis geste et la parole à un
florian et on arrivera si le souhaite
évidemment en arrivant au terme de nos
échanges
je vais être très bref parce que mes
mots seront les mêmes que les tiens
merci pour cette question parce que
c'est un sujet fondamental et voilà un
sujet sur lequel je crois la droite peut
marquer sa différence
on voit bien soit on est dans un
discours boboïsant dans lequel
finalement on fait plaisir uniquement et
bien à celles et ceux qui ont les moyens
ou la capacité de vivre et bien dans la
petite couronne parisienne
soit on traite le problème de fond est
donc il faut éviter la segmentation et
les politiques environnementales
compartimenté on l'a dit tout à l'heure
l'environnement c'est un enjeu de
société majeur ça nous concerne tous si
on commence à faire de l'environnement
un comportement individuel serre si on
commence à faire de l'environnement une
politique égoïste dans lequel finalement
on se dit on regarde uniquement ce qui
se passe dans ma ville et peu importe
les conséquences que ça aura pour les
autres je pense que ça c'est une grave
erreur parce que on va accentuer la
fracture territoriale de manière
dramatique encore plus forte que celle
qu'on a connue récemment ce que aurélien
a dit à juste titre derrière c'est la
question alimentaire c'est la question
des logements
c'est la question énergétique et donc
vraiment je crois qu on a une chose à
faire et à dire là-dessus et il faut
vraiment que nous
ans la politique écologique et que les
maires aussi et que les présidents de
région et de département pense cela nous
moi quand j'étais président département
quand on a construit notre politique
environnementale
on sait jamais dit mais on va déverser
nos déchets dans jura ou dans la saône
et loire ou ailleurs on n'a pas
construit comme cela surtout avec sous
le contrôle des jeunes var mais mais
mais je veux dire je crois que c'est
fondamental et j'ai peut être une image
pour justement pour terminer qui montre
bien ce que doit être la droite sur les
questions écologiques bio l'on dit
souvent mais quel est finalement la
différence entre entre la droite et la
gauche sur ces sujets comme comme sur
beaucoup de sujets et bien quand je
crois que la différence c'est que quand
il ya deux arbres et qui a un arbre qui
est plus grand que l'autre est bien
quand on est à gauche on coupe la rocqué
plus grand parce qu'on a une passion
égalitariste et bien quand on est à
droite on est de l'arbre qui est plus
petit agrandir pour arriver au niveau du
plus grand c'est comme ça qu'on a porté
la société merci damien florian quelques
mots et on sera à la conclusion de de
cette table ronde
mais écoutez c'est un sentiment très
positif que de savoir que le débat
pragmatique puisse exister finalement et
quand on revient au matériel et aux
tangibles on s'aperçoit qu'on revient à
nous mêmes et à notre maison vous avez
donc deux enjeux auxquels vous devez
être méfiant et c'est l'enjeu de la
virtualisation de nos modèles le premier
à démarrer en 1972 avec reagan et
thatcher la finance financiarisation qui
a démoralisé et qui a finalement fait
oublier à l'être humain l'enjeu matériel
pour lui donner un enjeu financier et le
deuxième qui a démarré au début des
années 2000 c'est la numérisation du
lien social c'est le digital finalement
qui est si vous lisez mon lit vous
verrez une formidable opportunité pour
construire cette nouvelle ère de progrès
est vraiment véritablement en revanche
elle amène l'esprit à se déconnecter de
la terre et quand on coupe le financier
ou la gestion financière d'un monde et
la gestion numérisés d'un monde
j'ai bien peur qu'on se détache de ce
qui nous ramène à l'essentiel à savoir
ce que nous sommes en tant qu'être
vivant dans son écosystème et dans
l'environnement
merci beaucoup merci à toutes et à tous
je
laisser la place à virgin du binaire qui
va animer la table ronde suivante
et merci à chacune et chacun d'entre
vous pour votre efficace participation
merci à nos intervenants pour leur
présence et leur contribution
[Applaudissements]